I wanted to talk about this yesterday, but didn't have time.
Last week after weeks and weeks of not taking questions in a press conference, after days of having
nothing public on his calendar whatsoever, Trump decided to do...
basically a campaign rally.
He went to Ohio to do a rally in front of a friendly crowd, kind of like what you do when you're running for president.
Supposedly, it was going to be an "Infrastructure" speech,
by the way,
how often is it Infrastructure Week? It seems like almost every week in this administration is Infrastructure Week.
Trump went completely and totally off the rails. It turned into a very strange, garbled rant
resembling the English language only loosely, and demonstrating a sort of Sarah Palin like
inability to communicate anything of meaning through language, and it got so bad that the three major cable networks CNN, MSNBC
and Fox News, all just cut away from the speech, although
you'll be pleased to know that good old Fox Business Network stayed with the entire thing all the way through.
Here is Fox bailing, when it got weird. Former George  W. Bush('s)
White House Press Secretary, Dana Perino, who's now a Fox News anchor, fittingly,
explaining that they are going away, and she looked sort of in physical pain as she said it.
[President Trump:]  32,000 soldiers... [Dana Perino:] Alright you've been watching President Trump, who is in Ohio giving a speech, a wide-ranging speech,
but mostly focusing on his infrastructure plan, and former White House Deputy Chief of Staff [during George W. Bush administration], Karl Rove is back with me.
I like that "wide-ranging" is code for "Trump is all over the place, real quick
go to Karl Rove to try to save us,  save us here." So even Fox cutting away even though
they did stay with it a few minutes longer than CNN and MSNBC.
So here are just random weird moments, the entire speech was totally off the rails, all right. Here's just a
random 20 seconds of Trump from the speech. [Trump:] Where a very important,
and respected,
in some circles,  Democrat,
said we want to get rid, we should get rid of our Second Amendment, in other words, get rid of it. That's really, ah,
[inaudible comment from audience], yeah,
[you] could be right about that!
So we're going to protect our Second Amendment. That's not going to happen. We have the best judges,
we put on a tremendous amount of great federal District Court Judges, will be setting records,
we are setting records,
appeals court judges, uh,
Supreme Court judge,
fantastic,
Justice Gorsuch,
What is he talking about setting records like what, what the hell is this guy on?
Just another few seconds from Trump's bizarre speech that networks couldn't even stay with: ...and we didn't have one Democrat who voted
for that. they want to raise your taxes and
they want people to come in from
the border, and they want,
I guess,
want? I can't imagine they want, but certainly drugs are flowing across borders. We need walls, we started building our wall,
I'm so proud of it. We started, we started, we have 1.6. billion,
and we've already started, you saw the pictures yesterday, I said what a thing of beauty, and on September 28th,
we go further... Yeah, that was a lie, by the way, the pictures
he's referring to, were from the replacement of 2 miles of border fence,
dating back to the 1990s.
Uh, we've got one more clip, again,
just disjointed rantings of a madman. We spent, and I was against it from the beginning, they try and say, "well
maybe not". I
was
against it from the beginning, and by the way,
we're knocking the hell out of ISIS, we'll
be coming out of Syria, like very soon. Let the other people take care of it now. [Applause]
Very soon, very soon. We're coming out. We're gonna have a hundred percent of
The Caliphate, as they call it, sometimes referred to as "land," taking it all back quickly, quickly.
Uh, but we're gonna be coming out of there real soon, gonna get back to our country, where we belong, where we want to be.
But just think of it, we spent, as of three months ago,
seven trillion dollars, not billion, not million.
Seven trillion with a "T"! Nobody ever heard of the word trillion until 10 years ago.
We spent seven trillion dollars in the Middle East.
We'd build a school they'd blow it up, we'd build it again, they'd blow it up, we'd build it again...
Hasn't been blown up yet, but it will be.
But if we want a school in Ohio, to fix the windows, you can't get the money. If you want a school in
Pennsylvania or Iowa, to get federal money, you can't get the money.
We spent seven trillion dollars in the Middle East, and you know we have for it? Nothing!
Remember I used to say, "keep the oil",
as a civilian!
I used to say, did anybody hear me say that? That's before I decided to go on this journey with all of you,
I got tired of watching.
What on earth is this guy talking about? I, it is the
disjointed rantings of someone who understands nothing. It's always
Infrastructure Week or Month, or whatever. Nothing actually happens except Trump just showing up and talking about his random, random musings here, and
it's, there's two phases of a Trump speech:
there's the horrible syntax of the teleprompter-reading, where he's looking off at an angle, and saying, "and
if we were to...
become a better nation of, and
then we would...".  Right?  It's like it's just he can't read it,
it just makes no sense, whatsoever, and then you see when he shifts off the teleprompter and
looks straight ahead, and, but then you don't even know what the guy's talking about, because he's just completely off the rails, and
improvising, and I hope that soon we actually get a press conference, supposedly, he's doing one today, uh,
questions like, uh, Mr. President, can you just say, definitively, did you have sex with stormy Daniels?
Did you realize that your people were knowingly and directly dealing with Russian intelligence officers?
Did you know about the hundred and thirty thousand dollars that Michael Cohen paid Stormy Daniels? Have you reimbursed? Some specific
questions, and you, you can't put him out there because he could end up saying something horribly self-incriminating.
So I hope we get a press conference soon. These
speeches are but so bizarre that even Fox News had to cut away from it.
Even if he did get those questions though, I think he would go off on a tangent about how he won the
2016 election; it was greatest victory of all times.
Something like that to deflect.
Maybe he would, but I think he would very likely end up saying something totally, totally self incriminating, and it's pretty clear
they're trying to keep him away from those types of questions.
Hopefully he will get some today.
Bizarre speech that a lot of people on our subreddit
noticed, and you can join that discussion, if you can stomach it, at davidpakman.com/reddit
Today's episode of the David Pakman show is made possible, in part, by Brilliant.
You watch the David Pakman show or listen to the David Pakman show,
so clearly you're interested in politics and in following what's going on in the world, and the economy, the environment,
but what's crucial to understand is that almost everything we talk about on this show,
is sort of on the foundation of math, science, and philosophy, and keeping up with the news is one thing,
but you're never really fully equipped to understand political issues and have debates with people
until you've actually developed a more complete understanding of how the world works,
and how these issues work at the most fundamental level, and
Brilliant is one of the most effective and enjoyable ways to do that, that I've ever come across.  You can learn
hands-on about statistics,
crime,
climate science, energy. It's a long list,
and you can get started right now, by signing up for free,
at brilliant.org/davidpakman  First two hundred people who visit
brilliant.org/davidpakman will also get 20% off an
annual premium membership. Check it out. Sign up for free today at brilliant.org /davidpakman